[Applause]
lifeguards are in high demand this
summer across the valley jeremy j ford
shows us where they are seeking out
employment
pools across clark county are currently
experiencing a lifeguard shortage but
it's water parks like this with
lifeguards like these that are staffed
up and manning the waters
with temperatures rising each week more
people are flocking to water parks even
pools on the strip
this is causing community pools to limit
its operation hours due to lack of staff
brent anderson is the water safety lead
at cowabunga canyon she says lifeguards
are working at other facilities instead
of community pools due to a more fun and
family-friendly atmosphere they do have
a very important job and they do have to
take a lot of responsibility in the job
but at a workplace like this we do make
it family oriented and we are there for
our lifeguards obviously we're
happy to have more lifeguards here and
welcome more people to the family but
we're just waiting for the moments to
work
currently water parks and hotels are
offering more benefits than community
pools to its seasonal employees this
including advancement higher pay and
paid lifeguard training
in las vegas jeremy j ford live local
down
anyone interested becoming a lifeguard
must be at least 15 years of age able to
pass lifeguard certification first aid
and cpr courses and in some cases like
the city of henderson you have to be at
least 16.